[Music]
what's that there's something crossing
up the head
keep the girls in the comments stay in
the car okay just stay in the car what
happened yeah
okay what's he saying
you are no stranger to action you know
pacific rim suicide squad hobbs and shaw
you've done it what was unique about
beast that maybe with the performance or
the setting or the scenario that you
hadn't experienced in your career yet
and and you were excited to take on this
challenge i mean you know
there's a lot of ingredients for this
film right it's a thriller as you said
it's lean um but there's an emotional
arc and there's a real physicality to it
you know some action characters don't
have an emotional arc or storyline and
you just get on with what that is but
this had a bit of all of it so for me it
was the first time juggling you know all
sort of pillars of what becomes you know
this performance this is the action part
which you know meant that i had to be
physically in shape and mentally in
shape because these are long days long
hours and then as a dad you know trying
to bring that real emotion to
you know this storyline of my guy and
his two daughters in this crazy thing
the friendship aspect and then we were
somewhere we were in you know the middle
of the wilderness where the environment
was one of the characters and this
wasn't like you know oh go to my sexy
trailer you know we were out in tents
basically um and it was it was it was a
labor of love yeah you're in it you know
uh
lions they have their pride they have
their family you know looking at that
word pride looking at yourself and your
career at this moment you know what are
you most proud of
uh i guess i'm most proud of just you
know
longevity
people
describe me as sort of an actor that has
a lot of range it makes me very proud
because you know i admire actors that
have a big range
i think you know just still being here
maybe audiences still want to see me in
films and that that feels good makes me
proud without a doubt they still want to
see you man you know uh
i'm somebody who geeks out on like how
things come together how a scene comes
together there's a scene in the trailer
in this film that you're fighting a lion
talk to me about how you film that
because you're not actually fighting
this giant lion so who are you fighting
how do you get your your head into that
space like break down how that scene is
like you know so it's it's a multiple of
sort of sequences stitch stitched
together you know i'm saying in terms of
how we make it and how the film is
actually shot sequence like in
rehearsals where you know uh it was a
guy called owen who's just like six foot
tall stunt guy you know he had to put on
his grey pants he didn't look cool at
all but he had this big line here and he
and i had to wrestle and choreograph
what that looks like and we spent
you know we spent a lot of time just
understanding the mechanics of an animal
you know like a lion and the size and
the strength and what that would do to a
human body you know this isn't a fight
between man and lion
let's be honest this is a lion attacking
a human being and he's trying to defend
himself
so that sequence end up in a lot of
rehearsals and then you know a marriage
between the animators and myself and
what we're shooting and how
that's gonna all happen was the first
time i was really really intricately
involved in the animation of stuff
because part of me had to be animated to
make this seem
incredible
and then it was you know
incredible rehearsals then we get to
location and then on location we shoot
this thing as we've rehearsed it
piecemeal so you know if you if you
watch the film
the the fight is a continuous movement
the whole time and we recorded all of it
but it took
like a week or two to do
yeah i love the way they shot those
those scenes the like the pov like it
just it immerses you in yeah you're
really you're in it yeah you know as we
start to wrap up you're a guy who uh the
rare actor who's been able to sort of do
both your marvel and your dc i just saw
you you had a little cameo in the last
thor movie at the end there uh if fans
of yours were to say where are we going
to see idris show up next in a marvel
project or a dc project what would you
say to them should i really say that
dc yeah yeah yeah there's something
something that's cooking over there
something really sexy is cooking that's
awesome that's awesome to hear
you know i think and also as you know
we're talking about these projects a lot
of people still want to see you as james
bond still want to see
yeah i remember you and you said you're
like i'm too old for jane you are not
too old man oh
my god i'd love to see you it's a will
of a nation that this joke the will of
of of the nation right now it's like you
know if it's to happen it's to happen
because you know what
people willed it to happen that's how it
works you know yeah is there is there
something that you haven't done yet in
your career you know all these big
franchises all these big blockbusters
that you've been a part of is there
still something out there that you're
chasing about a part kind of story no i
mean look you know
luthor right my character luther i
you know always wanted to see that film
come into
a a film that show turned into a film i
did that and and the goal is to take
luther into the sphere where the bonds
and the bonds are where it's essential
character you know so
if i haven't done anything yet is see
that journey all the way to the top and
that's what i'm trying to do
i've never seen anything like this
multiple attacks
without eating its prey
lies don't do that
at least no lion i've ever seen
all right so in this film you you are
like the expert you're a man of the land
uh you know we look to your character to
sort of let us know about the rules of
of this territory and and where we're at
so how much did you have to learn to
become that expert and what did was
there something that you did learn that
really opened up the character and the
story for you
i actually had
some experiences uh just learning about
lions before i did the movie
i went and spent some time with kevin
richardson who's a the lion whisperer
they call him he's a big guy on youtube
with lions
and so i actually learned at that time
from him that
lions when you engage lines in the way
that he for example plays with lions a
lot of the time you would watch
on youtube and you think like oh it's
like a cat it's like a house cat and
it's like the way you're gonna connect
with the lion is sort of gently and like
hey boy like
and when i met him and i saw how he
engaged them it's not it's like
you know kevin will say like
it's yo it has different personalities
like a cat whatever but it's not it's a
lion it'll kill you you know it'll eat
you if it senses even the slight bit of
fear
and so it looks all romantic and
whatever else but there is a sort of
alpha like he is the leader of the pack
of lions when you engage them so it's
it's a very different thing from
from playing with your house cats
and so i knew that coming in and that
was the most important thing that i had
to be able to do is how do you actually
physically engage lions well and you
have that scene in the film where you're
like hugging the lion and stuff and i i
find it so fascinating when lions are
like you know they use visual effects
and because it looks so real and that
moment especially looked really real and
so how did you film that and and just
talk me through that that blue that
scene blew my mind because i come from
visual effects and seeing those but
seeing the finished products
i still my brain sort of loops on itself
because the line because i know how
terrifying they actually are in real
life lions too unless you know how to
handle them and there's like three guys
in the world that can probably do that
so if they had said like you have to
come next to tame lions i'd be like this
is no way because i'd already been with
kevin i'd seen what a lion can do and
work what they all like um i shot with
stunt guys in with a stunt guy wearing
like a
gray
leotard
thing a typical thing the the paws
you know like these big uh plastic paws
and a plastic head that he would and he
would sort of have to look it's like the
worst version of a disney animated you
know sort of thing and then he had to
run and jump on me and like and like
sort of try and be intimidating but he
wasn't doing it enough so i kept teasing
him i'd be like come on man come on like
come like be a proper lion and he'd sort
of jump on me i was kept provoking him
and he was hot he was he was grumpy like
he's a grumpy stunt man by the end he
was genuinely getting annoyed because
it's boiling hot he's dying in that
thing
and um and that's how we did it and they
had to sort of like get the right line
moves and obviously knocking me and i'm
knocking them back
um
and just the end result is just it's
mind-blowing it looks awesome and i mean
you're shooting in south africa and so
like how much of being in that
environment helped you maybe bond as a
cast because you know you know this
family your character you're very close
so how much of just being in the
elements
uh helped you you bond and all of you
come together closer as an actor
you can't have it better than being in a
real place
in the real location and in this case
having a game farm we shot at this
farm it's uh called
baobab private reserve
these incredible bayer baptists one of
the most beautiful farms in south africa
at night we're having dinner every night
around the campfire as if we're guests
i mean people pay you know five thousand
dollars a night to go and do that and
you're doing that for like three months
with
it was just a dream and so it made a
huge difference we'd be having dinner
and then there'd be elephants coming
you'd hear elephants like do we have to
abandon dinner you know is it fine did
they close the gate how are the
elephants are getting too close
and then we'd sort of go off with our
flashlights to go and have a look at the
elephants at night it was amazing you
know i talked to somebody after they saw
this movie they're like i wanted to go
on safari with my family now i never
want to go on safari but i didn't
necessarily take that away i almost
watched this movie and i was like oh
that would be a really cool experience
i've been on safari in africa and it's
and it's wonderful i mean what when you
what do you want audiences to take away
f from a film like this
i think the
the beauty of africa the beauty of
nature
how little we have left of these types
of environments i went i got to you know
go into the bush on a bicycle a few
times
while i was shooting the movie just by
myself it was one of the most profound
things i've ever done in my life
just to remember just as a human to
understand like how vulnerable we were
at one point and how now how vulnerable
this environment is and how vulnerable
these animals are and how
quickly we could suddenly find ourselves
with none of this left
uh it would be very sad to not be able
to engage it you know i i have to ask
you because fans are always asking me
about you know another district movie
district 10 i know i know neil was
working on it
we were close we came super close and
then he's gone off to do something else
but we were right there we were kind of
right there
so
let's see in a year and a half after
when he gets done on the movies doing
now yeah you think so i think so it's
cool
and it's fun it's fun yeah i think it
will be i think it'd be cool
i would love to start off by just
talking about south africa and filming
in south africa i've actually um safari
in zimbabwe and it was one of like the
greatest experiences of my life like
such a memorable trip and i can only
imagine like shooting on location what
that was like for the both of you was
there a moment on set when you looked at
each other and it just kind of it was
incredible like being there and it was
surreal
and inspiring and it maybe even helped
you find your characters even even more
i think a lot of the times we like
looked at each other and just like thank
god we're here like we literally
couldn't believe that we're really
filming in south africa and i mean even
like on some locations we'd see the
other little kids and stuff and it just
felt like i don't know it just felt
surreal being out there and being able
to experience such a beautiful country
it's really beautiful out there yes
we almost couldn't have filmed in any
other place africa was
the most amazing place that i would like
i loved filming in it was
even though it was hot
i
i loved it there it was amazing just
seeing trees and all that stuff like
that like
and seeing the beautiful animals and the
wildlife africa is the nature of
wildlife so it couldn't get any better
and and you have to bond too you have to
become this family with idris and so
like what did you do together to sort of
become this family that was then off
ultimately in in peril
we hung out a lot outside of that even
like while we were filming too we were
like um
rapping and making jokes we had game
nights and dancing dancing
playing soccer like we just did so much
fun stuff like outside of just filming
because the movie can be kind of
emotional so we had to make sure like we
bonded outside of sets to just like
create that authentic chemistry which we
really do have yeah i heard there were
like campfires at night it was just
really kind of
cool like that's cool
it was amazing you know i i like geek
out on like how they make certain scenes
come to life and there's like a couple
of scenes when you're in the car and
like the lions come in and banging into
the car on top of the car and i would
love to get your perspective of like how
you filmed those scenes what was on the
car what were they banging into the car
with
so it was actually a funny story
it was never ever ever a lie it was just
a guy in a gray suit
with these huge big paws about like 10
inches wide and making the noises too by
the way just roar and then there was a
3d printed rubber lion face and he was
holding it on the handle it was very
heavy also but like just holding it and
getting it through
when we first filmed on the first day
and like well not the first day like the
first week and i saw it
my first mind was like oh lord what is
this
and in my head i'm thinking like this is
it or it's just like being funny but
then after a while though when we
started doing it though it was
we had to really get into character for
this we had to use our imagination a lot
for sure because again it's a man in a
suit so we have to like really act like
we're fighting for our lives
does it blow your mind too when you like
see
what what it looks like on the other
side and you see this line on top like
did it just blow your mind like that's
how it came together yeah it's really
amazing you know when it comes to like
what audiences will take away from this
film it's funny because like i've talked
to people about this movie and some
people are like i want to go on safari
now some people are like i never want to
go in safari in africa again like some
people everybody has a different
reaction like what do you hope audiences
kind of take away from this film because
there's a lot in this film there's
really great family there's really great
emotion emotions really great action
there's some really interesting facts
about lions and the way that they sort
of remain together as a family so like
what what do you hope audiences walk out
of theater what they take away from this
film
so many things but i think one aspect
can be like family like no matter what
you're going through with your family
like you can come together for a common
goal and and in this movie our common
goal is to literally survive so through
all of the ups and downs and all the
things we go through we want to live and
you you see that in the film just like
how we bond and we literally try and
figure things out
yeah like what she said i want i want
them to take away the the bond that we
had and how we depended on each other in
this this rough dangerous time in this
one little car and things like like
us just being there already is
already a bond so i want them to see how
much we have come together in this
family is stronger than the strongest
lie yes how we started and how we end it
and also don't poach let lake church let
nature just like you know because you
never know what can happen yes you meant
for that
we're in his territory now
it's the law of the jungle
it's the only law that matters
you i was looking at your filmography
and you've done survival type movies
before and what what attracts you to
that kind of storyline well i love the
the visceralness of a survival story you
know it's almost existentialistic and i
love the fact i remember i saw this film
come and see by emily
klimov i think uh pronouncing right back
and back when out before i became a
filmmaker and there was something about
a person going through it and and
when did you become an animal and
whenever you're a human being and and
and there's something i just
you know like i travel uh in my country
on horses across the country like for
two or three weeks in the summer and
it's very interesting to see how people
change once you get into it it all looks
very fun in the beginning
but we're just out of civilization and
characters of people
change and the real person comes out and
there's no hiding behind anything
anymore so i think there's something
that just appeals to me as a person and
i imagine being in south africa shooting
this film i mean how much of you know
being there in these surroundings how
much did that add absolutely crucial you
know i i uh when i was offered this
movie i said the first thing we have to
go traffic you know first of all
not telling them that was my childhood
dream you know when i came to my
mother's home for dinner before i left
and and i told her about the movies but
the shirt she brought out this clipping
book of lions in africa when i was a kid
i'd forgotten about it you know so i was
like i was economy like a veterinarian i
don't know what you know i live in
iceland there are no there's no wild
animal there so this was kind of a
fascinating uh very far away breed but
but uh but i was very you know that was
a big thing for me to show it because i
know also from everest on those you know
movies i made and and that the more you
get out of the nature the more you have
to drag the vfx to much real nature once
you're in a studio things start to kind
of wear off into into to wonderland you
know like but but once you have the real
baseline
which is african nature
the damn lion needs to look like it's
part of it you know so so now everyone
has to up their game so that's the part
of you know what how it's so important
and and it's also living living
the adventure myself you know yeah talk
about the way that you shot it too
because you do make a good point you
know these lions are are cgi
but it looks so real and the way you
shoot it from a pov perspective was was
super thrilling talk about coming up
with that strategy for shooting sort of
pov and what your overall strategy was
in terms of shooting those those action
scenes so so
once i started getting into it you know
and and i felt it very important to
to create this atmosphere and set it
apart from these kind of movies that
you've seen before not that they aren't
great it's just that you always want to
see something that's different and and
this isn't the style you're used to in
blockbusters they're long warners
but at the same time
this is not an art house
film so you gotta you gotta keep it
going so i felt like by putting you
getting you stuck in the shots when the
action is going
it adds to the to the claustrophobia to
the to the feeling of being of being
there with the family and never cutting
to the lion like oh it's there no you're
always there with them and it comes at
you so you are you're boxed in with them
and i think
but at the same time
when you have a family dinner or
something i'm not doing that because i
don't like to to force the audience to
something like which is just uh
manipulative in a way but as as the
action hits and the shots that you start
rolling and get more and more into it
they get longer and longer you know and
and it's a great challenge for a
filmmaker as well and i managed to
convince the studio which was a was a
bit of a challenge and and you know
bless them that they trusted me to do
this
but but but i think for me that's really
what what
kind of sets it apart in a way you know
and and also i do believe
for moviegoers that want something
different they will feel it because you
don't get that in any era it's a
feature creature great movie you know
don't move
okay
you know over the years you've become
such a prolific producer you just added
the oscars to your resume so i have i
have to ask i have to start off by
asking you what is the greater challenge
producing a movie or producing the
oscars oscars i always have to think
about it
just yes
oscars is like producing 10 movies
yeah
you know and speaking of this movie it's
been pitched as like cujo with a lion
why do you think that that was such a
great framework for a movie you know
first of all i'm a big fan of cujo i'm a
big fan of jaws like i just love those
survival thrillers i love those man vs
beast we talked about coming up with
something like that an incredible
creative name jamie premax sullivan she
was the one that brought me this idea i
was getting on the plane she text she
was calling me
and saying hey i got something i want to
picture i was like i'm about to take off
you know and she said okay just
cujo was a lion i think is what she said
and i'll i'll call call me when you land
and so that was like a four-hour flight
it's all in my head i couldn't like by
the time i landed i had this whole idea
for the movie in my head which matched
what she was thinking and ultimately
even though you know films go through a
lot of development it's kind of close to
what we came up with because we wanted
to have you know a guy idris amazing
who's better
in this situation with real stakes with
you know a strained relationship with
his daughters and now you drop him in
the middle of an actual crisis where
it's all about self-preservation i just
think those movies are fun
i think that when you do them right and
you have real stakes and you make it
experiential you put people in
the
pov of the characters i think that they
can be really really cool i think a
movie like this shouldn't take itself
too seriously but should still have
something to say and i think we do yeah
without a doubt you've worked with idris
before yeah uh six times this is our
sixth movie together yeah i i i think of
this christmas i think of obsessed first
of all i i think of obsessed can imagine
having idris and beyonce in a movie
these days
you gotta get that pairing again
in like 2023 yeah you know that's that's
a great pairing but i mean what is it
about your collaboration with idris
because every time you work with them
it's always like a different project
which i think is awesome yeah but what
is it about that collaboration that just
really works you know what it is the
collaboration industry is interesting
and it is always different because we
are very strategic in that we're
frequent collaborators because we
frankly we just we love each other you
know and we trust each other you have to
have that and he's somebody that's i
think absolutely the best of what he
does he wants every character to be
different he wants to be able to bring
something different to each character so
i don't bring him something unless i
feel like you know what this is
something you haven't done before and
you can bring something to this role
that somebody else can't right this is a
very different movie with a different
actor but the movie that we wanted to
make had the grounding had the
seriousness and had the jeopardy that
somebody with the gravitas of idris
brings to it you know you've been a
producer on shark week before so what do
you think you think we're getting lion
week after filming
yeah i have to call my friends over at
discovery and see i'm all for it listen
i will tell you i learned so much just
about lions about uh you know predators
and and alpha predators in the wild
it was really interesting to see up
close and personal because where we shot
you had all the animals that were there
and one of the things we did was we had
to create a watering hole
in order to shoot our scene it was a
watering hole that had dried up that
time of year we needed an actual
watering hole to be there so we created
a man-made one and animals they don't
know the difference so they started
showing up that was a little unnerving
you had to keep your head on a swivel
but it was just interesting because the
circle of life is real and uh being able
to highlight these rogue lions which of
course are man-made because poachers
separate them from the pride being able
to tell a story that's rooted in
something that's real that was important
for us too
when it comes to stories you tell so
many different stories i mean is there
still a story that you're chasing or
stories that you're chasing like what
haven't you done yet yeah that you still
want to do i don't know that i'm chasing
anything i just say that i'm always open
to doing new stuff i haven't done uh a
superhero movie yet i haven't done a
sci-fi yet um i've kind of dabbled in
horror but that's very interesting to me
like a like a true psychological horror
thriller you know going that route is
interesting so i'm always trying stuff
uh and so i don't know that it's like i
don't have my white whale but i
definitely just have areas where it's
like you know what when i get a chance
and something comes up that's right i
wouldn't mind dabbling in a particular i
want to see a superhero movie from you
what do you think like if you if you if
they give you an option say marvel or dc
you could do whatever which one would
you
is there something neither i'd say give
me something that is like an obscure
comic that people don't really know
about because i feel like there's so
much attention around the marvel and dc
universes but if there was an absolutely
very cool narrative and it wasn't
something that people were familiar with
that i could bring to life that's what
would be interesting to me
you